[Music]
it's hard to imagine
how a trusted british institution came
to shatter so many
ordinary lives there's no justice here i
said there that's it
there is no justice there was a day when
they came back with the word guilty and
the judge sentenced me
but after decades spent wrongly accused
bankrupted
some even imprisoned today dozens of
subpostmasters
have finally cleared their names
like see my mistress you're so
good sema was proud to become her local
postmistress
she never imagined then she'd be sent to
prison for a crime she didn't commit
i was scared i was lost i was completely
lost i was completely lost i was just
like where i'm coming or going i was
just like opening the post office was oh
my god there's another
it's just like piling up piling up sema
was accused of stealing
75 000 pounds because of a bug in the
software system
mistakes that a computer was making in
2010
she was sentenced to 15 months in prison
by a jury
at guilford crown court it was my son's
birthday
my son's 10th birthday and
when the judge said
i don't know what happened after that
i don't like did they even understand
the case they know like what are they
doing
so that type of loss to faith in the
justice i said
that's it nothing can be nothing can be
done that is there's no justice here i
say there
that's it there is no justice
there was a day when they came back with
the word guilty and the judge sentenced
me
sema was eight weeks pregnant with gyrod
when she was sent to prison
it's taken nine years for his mother to
clear her name
when i came out and that was
there was like a guilt there like i
thought i'm gonna put like a shame to
the family because going to prison
it's not it's not a nice thing they
can't bring back their time
will i be able to come out of with this
one i'm not sure i'm not sure
i would love to i still want to wake up
in the morning oh it was a bad dream
i hope sema wasn't alone
over more than a decade the post office
prosecuted hundreds of others
so what's it like being back at the post
office where all of this happened
it brings it home to you how long you've
been fighting really
you know it's like i was 45 when it
start it began
and here i am 63. joe hamilton
was accused of stealing 36 000 pounds
i phoned up for help and i didn't get
any basically
and the fact is whatever went wrong with
it you were liable for it and that was
the
the party line right from day one i
printed all this stuff off trying to
find out if i'd made
made a massive error somewhere and a
friend of mine came past through the
light on
um because it was 10 o'clock at night
and she found me literally
on the floor subbing trying to work it
out and she
she her advice to me was you were so
this has got to stop now the legal
advice i had then was they're going to
get you for false accounting and if you
plead guilty you'll have the sentence so
the best thing to do is raise the money
and plead guilty to false accounting
so um i felt i had no choice really so
that's what i did
and did you think you were going to
prison yeah my probation officer
told me and my pre-sentence report she
said to me
you're 75 likely to go to prison for
this so take your bag packed
prepare your shop to be without you um
and
yeah i hugged everyone goodbye and
didn't think i'd actually come out
but um i did i mean the judge was
totally dumbfounded by the amount of
people in court including the vicar
and um yeah it was quite a day
until today joe had a criminal record
but the villagers
never doubted her they rallied round and
helped her pay back the money she was
accused of stealing
passport check and send service the
history of the post office
the familiarity of a trusted institution
all comes with power to the post office
for the little things that make the big
things happen
the post office didn't oppose the
majority of the appeals today
in a statement they said they sincerely
apologize to the postmasters affected
by their historical failures they say
that throughout this appeals process
they've supported the quashing of the
overwhelming majority
of these convictions and the judgment
today will be an important milestone in
addressing the past
they also previously agreed a 58 million
pound settlement
with 550 postmasters in a civil case
58 million pounds might sound like a lot
of money but in reality most of that
went to the legal funders
many of the postmasters didn't even get
back the money that they've lost already
to the post
office but those who've had their
criminal convictions
overturned today could well now be in
line for
big compensation well it's an affront to
the public conscience effectively you
know this is something we should all be
ashamed of that
ever happened that's serious patrick
greene
is a barrister that worked on the civil
case it's an incredible victory
for the subposition some postmasters
and you know presumably some of them
will
seek to either agree compensation with
post office which might be the gracious
thing to do
or if necessary have to bring claims to
malicious prosecution
and if the post office decide to
litigate till the bitter end
will the postmasters be able to afford
to ever get the compensation they
deserve
well if they are able to get legal aid
to support them
then they'll be able to proceed with
their cases but if not
it's going to be very hard they're going
to have to try and get litigation
funding all over again
do you think we'll ever really see
justice for the postmasters
i i don't think so i'm afraid i'm sorry
to say
not full justice because money will
never compensate
these people for what's happened to them
today
the subpostmasters the ordinary men and
women
who lost everything at the hands of the
post office took on
a trusted institution and won
justice and proper compensation will
take longer
addy4 sky news